when you say that free will is necessary
in order to choose between truths in
order for you to say this one is true
and not this one
then it sounds like you're tying free
will to reason is that the case
or to rationality
to rationality yes absolutely no it's
not a matter of being true or not true
you know i mean
you you may buy an argument or not and
you may even change your mind in course
of time um
but
you need to be able to decide yeah now
this argument that i just
listened to
is convincing or no this is not
convincing enough
i'm not going to change my mind because
of that little argument so you need to
make decisions about what kind of
arguments you're going to buy and which
one you're going to reject
and so you need indeed this this ability
of
admitting or rejecting
arguments
in order to to start arguing or to to
enter any debate and again philosophy
science and all that
i have a quote from you which says free
will comes first in the logical order
indeed without free will there's no way
to make sense of anything and in
particular there would be no
understanding
remember earlier in the conversation i
said i i'm interested in the notion of
time free will
consciousness is well i see them as
intimately tied and you mentioned well
forget about consciousness who knows
about that
however right there you said free will
is tied to understanding now penrose
makes a connection between understanding
and consciousness i don't know if you
know that argument maybe not exactly i
i've read so many things from penrose so
probably it's maybe in the back of my
mind but indeed i absolutely correct i
mean free will in my opinion comes first
in the logical order
and because of that you know physics or
science or psychology whatever
cannot argue against free will
because it rests on freewheel
yes then now let's explain that because
even to me as someone who's been looking
into this that i found that to be a new
notion i didn't encounter that before so
firstly how did you come to that
conclusion and then can you explain that
conclusion
how did i came to it i don't know i you
know of your own free will you came to
i
i was thinking about free will and
randomness and
determinism and
passage of time
ever since i was a teenager
and so i don't there's not really one
point in time when suddenly aha now it
was so it's really something that
evolved
and at some point i was invited to a
conference to deliver a talk of course
and the conference was actually about
time and i was a bit surprised to be
invited but okay i thought this is
really a good chance and so i
i went to it and i i had of course to
prepare myself and that's actually when
i started really formulating these ideas
a bit more
in a more articulated way like uh you
know stating that free will comes first
in the logical order there is no
understanding without freewheel and so
on
but then also when i
uh
during
i think it was during that conference
some colleagues
mentioned in particular chris fox
mentioned to me
that there is an old
unknown essentially a french philosopher
le quiere
who actually had very similar thoughts
um
he was lucky he was also very much
influenced much more from myself
certainly my religious beliefs so god
was his problem how could god know
everything and me still having free will
that's the old version this is the
pre-scientist version of the free will
debate
and liquidate came to the similar
conclusion as myself but of course
centuries before
saying that actually free will comes
first
and uh without free will we cannot even
uh
yeah start this kind of argument about
god having a
full power and uh
and so on or full knowledge um
[Music]
yeah so so i noticed that i was not the
first and i thought that was kind of a
nice discovery for me
that this kind of idea were
not entirely new but clearly also not
very well known
now let's explain
what it means that free will comes first
in the logical order
if you start an argument
and don't have any free will
whether it is whether this argument is
going to resonate
is a purely let's say mechanical
stuff you know if i'm
hits my table here whether the tape is
going to resonate
is just a matter of the mechanics of the
resonant frequencies of this table and
so on and how i hit it and so on
but for an argument to resonate
in me
it's i think not just a matter of uh
i don't know it's not a mechanical
question
uh some arguments are convincing some of
us are not convincing and again that may
change in the course of time you don't
need to always be convinced by the same
argument during all your life span
so there must be something more and this
something more is actually what we name
free will this table has no free will it
doesn't decide to resonate to my hitting
it
uh while
you and me and everybody listening here
and so on
they may find
points and now my argument
uh
in that it resonates
to to them
or that they are willing to buy it or at
least to consider it or on the country
they will just reject it but whatever
they do it's like it's a free decision
it's something that depends on them it's
i don't think it is just a mechanical
consequence
of
you know of their bodies and their brain
and so on
so the way that i understand it is if i
was to make a bridge resonate i throw
wind at it and then it wobbles and
that's a physical process now if i throw
an idea at you or you to me if it
resonates with me we haven't we use the
same word resonate but we just mean well
we use the same word resonate that is
dependent not on the physics but on free
will
exactly i think that's that's exactly
yeah i think that that's correct of
course i know that some people will say
no no this is a purely a physical
phenomenon we don't i mean we first of
all don't exist it's everything is just
pure physics
but i think
um going that far
uh first assumes that physics really
explains everything
it all almost assumes in between the
line that today's physics is close to an
end
which are considered ridiculous
and
yeah and and i think it's uh
it bypasses
the beauty of life the beauty of
human beings including animals
of living living beings
what do your colleagues say to you when
you say
well perhaps physics doesn't explain
everything
the reductionist account including our
actions it goes from our actions to our
neurobiology to the chemistry to the
physics
and that's it physics that's it
yeah
again here um depends where we're
talking about today's physics or even
near future physics of physics in
general so science is not at the end and
will continue to develop and there will
be new ideas and completely new things
which will be
totally surprising to today's uh
physicists like quantum mechanics and
relativity are completely
foreign to uh 19th century physics
so there will be more revolutions
and um
so but maybe there's one thing which
seems pretty clear is that today's
physics doesn't explain free will
consciousness or things like that
could it be that future physics explain
it certainly not near future now what is
really the very far future of physics or
science more generally of course i don't
know
but my
claim is that free will being
first in the logical order
physics or science more generally and
philosophy will never be able to fully
explain free will of course we can
explain part of it for instance today we
understand much better from in the 19th
century
the difference between hardware and
software
and this distinction
which is very common today but this is a
useful distinction to to start even to
think about you know the brain as just
being the material part and maybe some
software whatever that exactly means
and things like that but at least we can
start articulating ideas
uh thanks to
this distinction between software and
hardware that were completely
unthinkable
uh 200 years ago 150 years ago
so so we can also expect that in the
future there will be new
concepts that's that we master or that
the future scientists will master
and that will help
uh better articulating the problem of
free will and consciousness and so on
but i don't think we will ever come to
an end in that if we will we somehow
some essence of free will
will always remain
outside the scope of of science
and now yeah you also asked about my
colleagues
my colleagues
there are many colleagues and i would
say the vast majority of the physicists
just don't care they are not going to
listen at all we just don't care
now among those that care
you know
they care after a few years
usually
and
most of them which when
i don't know
i would they would listen to what i have
to say they would not necessarily agree
okay some have very strong opinions they
are strongly compatibilist but they
really thought about it that's okay
um
[Music]
and i guess we also quite a lot and i
have already experienced quite a lot of
my colleagues who are happy with what
i'm saying
but you know the happy is a small
minority seriously unhappy is also a
small small minority and the enormous
majority just doesn't care
and why do you think the majority
doesn't care
it's too ill-defined they'll say
yeah it's too ill-defined it's
i don't exactly know how how they can
not care about such important and deep
questions
maybe we just think that uh you know
they have not been trained in that so
they don't feel uh
competent
in this in this respect somehow
probably also if some of my colleagues i
tell them about some
subtleties in biology they may also just
say oh i don't understand it it's
outside my field of competence
actually nowadays we get so specialized
that you don't even need to change field
and go outside of physics
for not understanding what the colleague
is saying
um
and maybe it is uh
it is
yeah it's a way of protecting yourself
just to say no notice i don't want to
touch it's outside my little field
of competence